Yeah,
he's a,
he enjoys it and he seems to like want you to enjoy it too.
He's like,
all right.
That went amazing.
You know,
it's like,
come on,
let's get some deep breaths.
You're doing fantastic.
Yeah.
In between 'em round with Michael Bisbing,
there's a five round fight.
Um,
he comes in and tells me,
he,
he told,
he told me like a knock,
knock joke and then why a chicken crossed the road joke.
And I sitting there and there's a picture of me like quizzically looking at him,
I'm like,
I'm going to kill you.
And you're like,
what are you doing?
And he just wanted me to relax.
He just wanted me to breathe when,
because I was doing everything I was supposed to be doing and um,
I just needed to,
you know,
he just thought you were two tents.
Yeah.
Apparently.
Huh?
What a Dick playing mind games in the middle of,
in the middle of a fight.
You have one minute to figure out what to do and what to say to a guy who just
was,
well,
some people bonds for five minutes.
Yeah.
Some people have a little more.
Do you know that?
I discussed that yesterday with big John Big John,
the podcast yesterday.
We fucked up and he forgot to talk about it during the podcast,
but after the podcast he explained what happened.
He says that it was the UFC cut man's fault cause he left a giant Glob of
Vaseline on yokels.
I,
he didn't want to touch it because he felt like if he touched it could open the
cut up again.
Yeah,
he called the,
I guess it was the guy's name,
Tate.
He tried to call and get the guy to come back in.
The guy wouldn't come back in,
so the corner men tried to come in.
He said No.
He's like,
you got to bring the cut man back.
And then he wound up doing it by himself.
It was the perfect storm.
He said he fucked up and said,
Yo,
I was definitely playing it off.
And he said,
but if he had to do it differently,
he would had a made UL stand up and be,
he would've made sure that fucking cut man didn't leave the cage with that big
Glob of asset on that.
I was just talking crap.
Oh,
I was actually complaining about.
Yeah,
it was.
Um,
so,
but that was a giant issue.
It was a 32nd 32nd issue for a guy who was really wobbled at the end of the
second round and my route to the title.
Yeah.
It was a big deal.
It was a bummer,
but it was the perfect storm,
you know,
and,
and um,
and now he's fighting for the title,
so,
you know,
hopefully he represents Cuba.
Well,
he's a bad motherfucker.
Yeah.
He's a freak.
He really is right.
Specimen.
Yeah.
I mean,
when like,
there's so much going on there.
It's like there's the years of training and that crazy Cuba Olympic program,
there's phenomenal genetics is experience and competing.
There's so much going on there with that guy.
Layers and layers and layers of the highest level of competition,
um,
mixed in with a life that I think has been very complimentary to a mindset of an
athlete.
You know,
he,
he has pretty much been shaped most of his life to be a highest level athlete.
Um,
tricky part is math.
Whitaker's good Whittaker is very good.
It's very good.
It's very good and very young,
you know,
and a Whitaker,
you gotta remember had his knee blown out in the first round.
He got his knee high,
Brixton at tourists,
MCL pretty badly in the first round and still was able to stuff takedowns and
arguably the best wrestlers ever fought in MMA.
Yeah,
pretty impressive shit.
That's great fight.
That's a couple of weeks from now.